[Music]
alex is with us in montana hi alex
welcome to the ramsay show
thanks for taking my call dave and john
sure what's up question for you a
question for you about a bachelorette
party hey you you asked the right two
guys we both are absolute experts on
bachelorette parties
i can't wait for this great hopefully
you can help
for sure i
i am the maid of honor for my good
friend
and she's
thinking of inviting quite a few girls
to her party
and looking at some pnps price ranges
like 1500 to 2 000. dollars for the
weekend
so
just wondering
i don't want to confront
money i don't want to be the one to
reserve it
unless i have you know some payments up
front
but i don't really know how to tell her
that or
suggest maybe she wants to put her card
down
i'm just looking for some guidance on
what i should say i think guidance
number one i'll give you is two words
pedal tavern
that's what i'm saying
if you want to get an airbnb and make it
on a nice fancy weekend
john
yeah can't take this guy anywhere all
right no pedal taverns john
you might be a redneck if your
bachelorette party is on a pedal tavern
or you might live in nashville john
you know or you might have come to
nashville yeah those things are a blight
on our city uh all right so um
wow
1500 bucks what do you make a year
uh about 80. okay
i make my husband makes 55
and we're just working on paying off our
house but
he's more like we do not need to be
okay you know anyone alex if i'm
thinking alex if i'm you i'm jumping
right in the middle of this and gonna be
just clean and clear and direct and
honestly i'm rather emotion free
get the list of the names and send them
out and say hey i'm gonna make this
thing i need everybody's money by this
date um otherwise i'm not gonna i'm not
gonna put it forward and then mow me the
money and we'll call it good i mean i
would just i would be that clear about
it right
but in terms of like i haven't talked to
her about it so
you know do i just say like um if you're
responsible for throwing the party and
for pay and for putting the money up
front you don't even need to talk to her
you you need to have the list and you
send it out like john said
now you're not asking mr and miss
manners here because we don't have any
manners we're just telling you how to
get the money yeah
yeah okay and i okay
i i i think be real clear with her and
you've here's the deal you're an adult
and you gotta have adult boundaries and
if you're not going to here's what's
gonna happen
you're gonna end up putting this on your
own you're going to pay for it some
people aren't going to pay you back and
you're going to get mad at her because
you didn't have boundaries
don't do that
have all your boundaries up front and
say
if you have to have that conversation do
it i don't think you have to like dave
said i don't think you got to call her
and say i'm not putting this money on my
no just say give me the list of the
names how long how long have you known
them
abroad
yeah for a while probably
i don't know over 15 years
50
15. oh okay one five okay i was thinking
the pedal tavern definitely ain't
working um
okay
i will pay for that one
okay so here's the thing i mean in your
relationship with stems when did y'all
your childhood friends or what
yeah probably in middle school
so if i'm in your shoes and i have a
household income 120 000 bucks if i get
half the money i'll put the other half
in and i'm gonna call it a day a
thousand bucks i love this lady she's my
best friend this is childhood i'm in her
i'm in her wedding i'm made of honor and
you do the best you can to collect it
and you release this
and be chill about it
um but yeah you do get a list of names
and so here's how you venmo it and i
expect you to pay your part and there it
is and be nice and kind and clear
and you don't really have to ask the
bride's permission to do that you're the
one paying for it
that's nothing to do with etiquette or
manners we don't know that this is the
ramsey show